get a telescope because with a telescope
unlike any other piece of scientific
apparatus you can not only replicate the
discoveries but you can replicate how
they felt what Galileo saw when he
turned this tiny little telescope and he
looked at the Moon it has these weird
holes on it maybe I have a hypothesis
and that those craters are caused by the
impact of meteors or asteroids hitting
into the surface Jupiter has four
enormous moons that you can see through
a telescope from right here in the Heart
of Los Angeles you can see the exact
same things that he saw and you can feel
the things he felt how often do you
experience a visceral Sensation that
unites you with a great scientist from
human history it doesn't matter you are
not the first person to make the
observation you're making it the first
time for yourself so I tell all parents
do that for your kids